welcome to the coverage of the first day
of the Chess Club Invitational here in
st. Louis we're actually having two
tournaments ongoing the Grandmaster norm
and the International Master norm
tournament in a battle of international
masters can happen priyadarshan defeated
Darwin yang in the first decisive game
of the first round hi always started
with a French defend that i was playing
white with davon yeah and we played at
arash system and i played f4 on move 06
was the first time i'm trying the system
and for him so it was the first time
that he's playing the night d7 system
with josh and basically a he played a
five and which was not so popular plan
and I don't think which is so accurate
and I don't know what I fleas how light
reacts I just played a normal developing
moves the subsequent moves he was
playing he was just pushing the point
forward a 5 84 83 and I think I had a
huge development lead by this position
and white is slightly better already and
then open at one point his whole play
was focused on the C file and I was
trying to attack his gangster and I
think g4 was quite a good move that i
showed my aggressive intentions to
starting out to attack and he had to
find like the best McQueen said what he
what he played was the best McQueen to
see 8 and then he was already very less
on time I had like half an hour lead in
a clock and Bishop I played night g3 at
the pawn part of the game and he played
Bishop b5 which had calculated for quite
a long time and I found that all the
complications lead to a favorable
position for white so and he as he had
very less time he couldn't Cal get all
the complications and he made a mistake
I would say that's by giving me two
pieces for a route with this King still
on the center that position was
disadvantage for me
all after that I did was just simply
outplayed him slowly and as the first
step of my plane was I exchange a queen
which was exposing me some problems if
he had a screen on his board so once I
exchanged screen it was nothing I just
had two pieces for a route that was a
material and balance we had we had other
pieces on the road but I think had an
order chances are going to play it was
it was just crushing after that for
right and as we look at the Grand Master
standings after round one you can see
that these three players at the top
including priyadarshan left the round
with one point also in the first round
women's I am inna aggressed defeated
Doug Eckert with the black pieces I
think this point is the critical point
in the game because so far we could
black is worse but seems to be holding
that position at the moment I think the
best move for white in this position
would have been aged for end not so
clear what I will do because white has a
lot of time and can do basically
anything leave the king and black
doesn't have that many moves because if
I move to if I move night somewhere don
t five squares bad remove the bishop
down the c6 square root guess ordering
be sick so i will probably have to play
something like h6 maybe between age
seven so that the night won't have any
checks but he played h3 which is
probably very close to blunder because I
get to play g5 and suddenly the position
turns around a little because I get some
play and in the international master
norm tournament two players including
inna left the round with one full point
we hope you continue to join us in these
round recaps every day round start at
11am and 5 p.m. here at the club in st.
Louis if you'd like to attend the
tournament goes through Friday